[Musique]
tommy le 5 avril dernier vous êtes suivi
en voiture par la police j'étais arrêté
par l'appareil par les policiers parce
que j'ai refusé m'arrêter parce qu'en
fait possible usurpation d'identité
je n'ai plus de permis de conduire vous
allez philapostel il ya bien j'ai refusé
m'en arrêter les policiers mais son
entrée dans par derrière à ce moment là
moi j'ai touché j'ai gardé un cas et je
me suis laissé faire et de la
directement ça commence c'est sale arabe
et a rien à faire en france on rentre
chez toi alors qu'ils allaient ma carte
d'identité française
la carrière à ce moment là j'ai un
policier qui monte dans le coffre pour
m'étrangler
ils exigent souvent molière témoin le
policier qui était sur ma gauche il a
directement commencer hamas signé
plusieurs coups de poing au niveau de
l'abdomen et ça s'est répété à quatre ou
cinq reprises et moi ce moment-là je me
dis mais c'est fini pour moi je vais
mourir
j'ai suivi l'affairé georges frêche je
veux bien fait la cij de mourir
d'instruction aujourd'hui c'est vraiment
de la fouille que les choses vont aller
encore plus loin
vous enlevez vos vêtements quand vous
arrivez au commissariat j'enlève mon
pantalon et chaussures
les policiers me demande que j'avais mon
caleçon g200 caleçon et à ce moment là
j'ai un des deux policiers qui eux j'ai
tout oit
accroupis toi et tous en ce moment là à
ce moment là j'ai un policier qui se
jette sur moi qui le trouvent notamment
à ce moment là j'ai besoin pour se dire
qu'ils soient au niveau des gens mais
qui nous donne des coups de poing qui
était ce vraiment violent j'avais le
souffle coupé
j'ai tant qu en son nom serait d'écouter
j'étais étranglé à ce moment là j'ai
pris ces clichés intentions le collège
chez intel son camp l'action qu'elles
sont trop disent notre audience doit
dans mon top
battus parce que seulement 70 ans
j'étais tout jeune étudiante
il s'est arrêté d'autres agents
pouvaient plus depuis le départ tout
porter ça se passe bien je te ferai
j'étais tabac ce qui pouvait plus ici la
personne qui est intervenu à ce moment
là je suis au sol et un policier qui
sort son téléphone et qui le
photographient psychologiquement on vous
sent vraiment très très très marquée
briser psychologiquement je suis détruit
trois jours avant d'aller aux toilettes
il avait une bonne ou touche et on est
très touché un parent et moi je me sens
extrêmement sincère je vous le dis à
tony sachez que les policiers ont
également porté plainte contre tommy
pour rebellion vous tiendra au courant
de cette affaire et on va faire on va
enquêter auprès bien sûr de la police
des polices